hey guys how's it goin welcome back to
cooking with Justine guess what we're
gonna make today no guesses okay I had
this really great idea to make a big
Oreo okay let's get started
set up into 350 done coat bottom of pan
with no stick not done cool
there's measuring stuff on here and I
didn't even know it how long have I been
doing this a long time oh yeah 1 cup
water boil 1 do I think I'm getting good
at cooking Hey
like I'm look I think I'm good at it
like I think I might have a future
combine it alright I'll do whatever you
want me to do alright this is on you
look great nice little pulse
[Music]
we've got our two pans here and I'm
going to put our mixture are you ready
come and get it just a little bit for
you for you and a little bit for you
this is gonna work out exactly like I
had in mind all right things are going
nicely things are really progressing the
way that they should so I completely
forgot that I wanted to put Oreos inside
of this batter so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna put some Oreos in here
confection
Kobe Kobe beef
oh I blocked that shot like I can't name
a single basketball player I think I can
do it what's gonna happen
we've got a full container of Oreos I
don't know what's gonna happen I'm an
actor with some milk or something in
here what am i doing is there a kill
switch on here hmm okay I don't think
this is gonna work like I think it's it
should
[Music]
I lost the plunger to this so scares me
with each press
I smell burning okay that looks good
cord oh my oh gee where's my phone
well I see cakes burnin holy hot do you
think that's done it's a little wobbly
okay we're gonna let these cool off and
then we're gonna start the decorating if
that's what you want to call it now it's
time to make the Oreo magic happen let
me retrieve my cakes from the fridge
we're gonna flop this that worked quite
easily so if you want to put it this
side up though mm probably not a good
idea usually I have really bad ideas
let's just put the filling in Oh
it's sugar-free great real
health-conscious clearly in goes oh boy
it's still a little sugar free icing
sucks it tastes awful it's like hey are
you trying to beef it no if I was I
would be making myself a salad all right
you just want to ice it real good real
nice yeah we're gonna take this one
[Music]
that's it Oh God Hubble this looks like
some dog just came along and dropped a
huge turd right on top of it smooth it
with my fingers Oh God
oh I'm disgusted oh my gosh Genco gonna
close up it's the Oreo mixture let's put
Maggie in there oh my god it's like tar
it's so sticky here's the Oreo I'm gonna
see if I can pick it up like an actual
Oreo okay I am holding this up with two
hands I can't fit it in my mouth oh yeah
not tweeting - what's it thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this amazing Oreo cake big Oriya I'm not
really sure whatever you want to call it
let me know what you guys would like to
see me cook in the comments below and I
will see you guys in the next video make
sure you guys like and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel I'm gonna break
bread with you
[Music]
sugar-free sucks okay bye
look Chloe started
alright well crap
[Music]